وصلت ذكاء الاصطناعي الى حد اختراع ما لم
يتوقعه احد من قبل وهو محامي روبوت ليكون
الاول من نوعه الذي يساعد مدعي عليه في
قضيه في المحكمه شهر فبراير المقبل في
الولايات المتحده الروبوت التي تم تطويره
بواسطه شركه تسمى دونت بي يعمل على هاتف
ذكي ويستمع الى الحجج في المحكمه ويصيغ
الردود للمدعى عليه كما يخبره بما سيقوله
في الوقت الفعلي من خلال سماعات الراس
تتعلق قضيه الروبوت الاولى بمخالفه السرعه
تم اصدارها ضد المدعي عليه والذي سيقول
فقط الاشياء المواجهه اليه من قبل روبوت
بكاء الاصطناعي بعد ان يعالج ويحلل
المعلومات التي يتم الاستماع اليها في
المحكمه قد تكون تكلفه التعيين وحامله
الدفاع في قضيه مخالفه السرعه بواحده
الثمن ويمكن ان تكلف بين 200 الى 1000
دولار اعتمادا على ظروف القضيه ووافقت
شركه يونايتباي على تغطيه اي غرامات اذا
خسروا القضيه